THE STORY GOES ON TOMORROW.
WE WILL SEE YOU THEN.
HAVE A GOOD NIGHT, EVERYBODY.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
WE LIVE, AS YOU MAY HAVE
NOTICED, AND THE AGE OF WOKE
CAPITAL.
NOT JUST SELLING PRODUCTS, WE
ARE SELLING MORE THAN THAT.
YOU SEE IT EVERYWHERE.
YOU SEE IT IN EVERY MOVIE COME
EVERY COMMERCIAL, REPRESS
RELEASE FROM THE DIVERSITY
DIVISION OF YOUR LEGAL HR
DEPARTMENT.
THE MESSAGE IS ALWAYS THE SAME.
COMPANIES AREN'T JUST SOULLESS
PROFIT SEEKERS, THEY ARE MORE
THAN THAT.
ARE THEY THAT HAVE VALUES AND
THEY HAVE PRINCIPLES.
THEY CARED.
THEY PROBABLY CARE MORE THAN YOU
DO.
ONCE UPON A TIME CORPORATE
AMERICA FLATTERS ITS CUSTOMERS
AND NOW THEY DARE YOU TO BE AS
VIRTUOUS AS THEY ARE.
IS THAT REAL?
ARE THEY ACTUALLY VIRTUOUS?
OR IS ALL OF THIS A CYNICAL
POST?
WE WILL LET YOU DECIDE.
CONSIDER THIS.
LAST FRIDAY DARRELL MOORINGS,
THE GENERAL MANAGER OF THE
HOUSTON ROCKETS BUS WHILE TIAN
SAID WHAT SEEMED LIKE A
NONCONTROVERSIAL TWEET.
HE WROTE THIS.
FIGHT FOR FREEDOM, STAND WITH
HONG KONG.
THAT'S IT.
NOW CHINA, AS YOU MAY HAVE SEEN,
IS NOW TRYING TO CRUSH HONG KONG
AND IT'S NOT HARD TO PICK A
SIDE.
CHINA IS A RACIST XO STATE THAT
BANDS DISSENT AND MURDERS OF
CLIPPED POLITICAL OPPONENTS.
IF YOU WOULD THINK EVERY
AMERICAN WOULD STAND WITH
HONG KONG WITHOUT EVEN THINKING
ABOUT IT.
BUT NOT THE NBA.
THE NBA IS ON CHINA'S SIDE.
SO HE WAS FORCED TO DELETE HIS
TWEET.
THE NBA ISSUED A STATEMENT
MAKING IT CLEAR THAT UNDER NO
CIRCUMSTANCES DO THEY SUPPORT
HONG KONG OR HUMAN FREEDOM.
TODAY BASKETBALL COMMISSIONER
ADAM SILVER EMERGED CLARIFIED.
HE REPEATED THE FOR REFRAIN OF
EVERY PERSON WHO OPPOSES FREE
SPEECH.
SURE, YOU AREN'T SAFE FROM THE
CONSEQUENCES.
SPEAK OF THE LONG-HELD VALUES OF
THE NBA ARE TO SUPPORT FREEDOM O
THE NBA ARE TO SUPPORT FREEDOM F
EXPRESSION.
DARYL MOREY IS THE GENERAL
MANAGER OF THE HOUSTON ROCKETS
AND ENJOYS THAT RIGHT AS ONE OF
OUR EMPLOYEES.
WHAT I ALSO TRIED TO SUGGEST IT
IS I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
CONSEQUENCES FROM THAT EXERCISE
IS IN ESSENCE HIS FREEDOM OF
SPEECH AND YOU KNOW WE WILL HAVE
TO LIVE WITH THOSE CONSEQUENCES.
>> Tucker: SO IT'S NOT HARD TO
SAY THAT WE SUPPORT FREEDOM
AGAINST OF THE FASTEST
GOVERNMENT OF CHINA.
APPARENTLY IT IS.
STEVE KERR IS THE COACH OF THE
GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS APPEARED
ON THE QUESTION OF AMERICAN
POLITICS, YOU MAY HAVE NOTICED
HE HAS NO PROBLEM SPEAKING HIS
MIND.
HE EMBRACES THE HARD LEFT
SOCIALIST POLICY.
HE DOESN'T HESITATE TO DEMAND
STRICTER GUN LAWS FOR THE REST
OF US.
IN THE WORDS OF ONE FAWNING
MEDIA OUTLAY, THERE ARE MANY, HE
SPEAKS TRUTH TO POWER.
ALL RIGHT.
SO WHAT TRUTHS WERE HE READY TO
SPEAK TO CHINA?
NONIT TURNS OUT.
NOT A SINGLE TRUTH TO THE
GOVERNMENT OF CHINA.
CHOOSING BETWEEN FREEDOM AND
FASCISM TURNS OUT TO BE REALLY
CONFUSING CHOICE.
WHO KNOWS WITH THE RIGHT ANSWER
IS.
IT'S AS YOU POINTED OUT, IT'S
REALLY ABOVE HIS PAY GRADE.
>> BIZARRE INTERNATIONAL STORY.
A LOT OF US DON'T KNOW WHAT TO
MAKE OF IT SO THERE IS SOMETHING
I'M READING ABOUT JUST LIKE
EVERYBODY IS BUT I'M NOT GOING
TO COMMENT FURTHER.
>> Tucker: NOT GOING TO
COMMENT FURTHER.
A BIZARRE INTERNATIONAL STORY.
IN OTHER WORDS STEVE KERR IS A
PHONY.
HE'S BRAVE WHEN THE CROWDS
APPLAUD BUT WHEN MONEY IS AT
STAKE, HE SHUTS UP AND OBEYS
LIKE THE COWARDLY LITTLE
CORPORATE STOOGE THAT HE IS.
IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE HOW A MAN
LIKE THAT CAN LOOK HIMSELF IN
THE MIRROR AT NIGHT.
YET HE'S NOT ALONE.
HARDLY.
THERE ARE COUNTLESS STEVE KERR'S
IN CORPORATE AMERICA.
ALL OF THEM HAPPY TO LICK THE
BOOTS OF THEIR CHINESE MASTERS
FOR PAY.
THEY JUST BANNED A TOP PLAYER
FROM ONE OF ITS GAMES BECAUSE HE
GAVE AN INTERVIEW SUPPORTING THE
DEMONSTRATIONS IN HONG KONG.
JUST LAST YEAR RIGHT OUTSIDE OF
WASHINGTON, THE HOTEL COMPANY
MARRIOTT FIRED ONE OF ITS
EMPLOYEES.
WHY?
FOR LIKING A TWEET THAT
RECOGNIZED TAIWAN AS A COUNTRY.
THAT'S IT.
THAT TWEET OFFENDED CHINA.
SO MARRIOTT DID THE BIDDING OF
THE FASCISTS AND FIRED HIM.
THAT ACTUALLY HAPPENED.
THIS IS COMMON BY THE WAY.
IN HOLLYWOOD PANDERING TO CHINA
IS SO COMMON AND SO FRAGRANT
THAT THE SHOW SOUTH PARK
PRODUCED AN ENTIRE EPISODE
MOCKING IT.
>> WE WANT THOSE CHINESE
VIEWERS.
>> SERIOUSLY?
>> IT'S OKAY.
THERE'S PLENTY OF OTHER THINGS
TO TALK ABOUT WITH YOUR STORY.
HOW ABOUT WHAT KIND OF THINGS
YOU ARE INTO YOU WHEN YOU WERE A
YOUNGER?
>> I ALWAYS LIKED
WINNIE THE POOH.
>> NO.
THAT'S DEFINITELY OFF LIMITS.
WINNIE THE IS ILLEGAL IN CHINA
BECAUSE SOME CHINESE STUDENT
SAID HE LOOKS LIKE THE CHINESE
PRESIDENT.
>> COME ON THAT'S RIDICULOUS.
>> Tucker: MAY BE RIDICULOUS
BUT SOUTH PARK WAS BANNED IN
CHINA AFTER THE EPISODE YOU JUST
SAW.
YOU GOT TO RESPECT THE CRATERS
FOR MAKING THE EPISODE ANYWAY
AND A COMEDY CENTRAL FOR AIRING
IT.
MOST COMPANIES IN AMERICA WOULD
NEVER DO THAT.
WHY?
YOU KNOW WHY.
CHINA HAS 1.4 BILLION PEOPLE.
COMPANIES WANT ACCESS MARKET.
IF IT IS A CHOICE BETWEEN
SUPPORTING THE UNITED STATES,
OUR COUNTRY, AND OUR PEOPLE, OR
GETTING RICH IN CHINA, IT'S NO
CONTEST FOR MANY COMPANIES.
FOR DECADES NEOLIBERALS ASSURED
US THAT IT WAS OUR DUTY TO
EMBRACE FREE TRADE WITH CHINA AS
THE REST OF IT SAT BY AND TRY TO
STEAL TECHNOLOGY AND STATURE OF
OUR PROPERTIES IN CITIES DRIVING
UP THE RATES AND THE RENTS AND
DECREASING THE RATES OF
HOMEOWNERSHIP AND DESTROYING
MILLIONS OF MANUFACTURING JOGS
MAKING A COMMUNIST COUNTRY --
CHINA INEVITABLY --
THESE THINGS ARE ALWAYS
INEVITABLE, THAT WOULD BECOME
MUCH FREER.
THAT WAS IN EXPLORABLE BECAUSE
CAPITALISM ALWAYS LEADS TO
DEMOCRACY.
REMEMBER THAT?
THEY WERE LYING.
IT TURNED OUT TO BE COMPLETELY
FALSE.
INSTEAD OF EXPORTING AMERICAN
FREEDOMS TO CHINA, OR RULING
CLASS INSTEAD IMPORTED CHINESE
AUTHORITARIANISM HERE.
30 YEARS LATER ORDINARY
AMERICANS ARE POOR AND ALL OF US